THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
WE START WITH ERIC BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
BREAKING MOMENTS AGO, WE LEARNED
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
SUBMITTED WRITTEN ANSWERS TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
AND THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY,
JAY SEKULOW, ISSUED THIS
STATEMENT."
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT RESPONDED
IN WRITING.
RUDY GIULIANI ADDING THAT IT HAS
BEEN OPPOSITION FROM THE OUTSET
THAT MUCH OF WHAT HAS BEEN
RAISED CALLS FOR SERIOUS
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES AND IS
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF A LEGITIMATE
INQUIRY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS NONETHELESS
PROVIDED UNPRECEDENTED
COOPERATION.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS BEEN
PROVIDED WITH MORE THAN 30
WITNESSES, 1.4 MILLION PAGES OF
MATERIAL AND NOW THE PRESIDENT'S
WRITTEN RESPONSES TO QUESTIONS.
IT IS TIME TO BRING THIS INQUIRY
TO A CONCLUSION."
MAKE NO MISTAKE, HUGE WIN
TONIGHT FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS LEGAL TEAM.
HIS ATTORNEYS WERE PUSHING FOR
WRITTEN ANSWERS.
THAT MEANS NO SUBPOENA FIGHT, NO
SUBPOENA BEFORE THE GRAND JURY,
NO IN-PERSON INTERVIEW, NO
YEAR-LONG FLIGHT HEADED TOWARDS
THE SUPREME COURT, NO PERJURY
TRAPS, AND KEEP IN MIND, THESE
WERE ALL QUESTIONS, NONE OF THEM
WERE ABOUT OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
WHY?
BECAUSE THERE NEVER WAS ANY,
JUST LIKE THERE WAS NEVER A
COLLISION.
INSTEAD, MUELLER FOCUSED ON THIS
RUSSIA COLLUSION AND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN, THE PRESIDENT HAS
ALREADY ANSWERED THESE
QUESTIONS, DENIED ANY COLLISION,
ANY CONSPIRACY, ANY COORDINATION
WITH ANY FOREIGN GOVERNMENT,
ESPECIALLY RUSSIA.
NOW THIS HAS JUST BECOME A
FORMALITY.
AFTER SPENDING NEARLY 600 DAYS,
THE INVESTIGATION MIGHT SOON
FINALLY BE COMING TO AN END.
THE MEDIA HYSTERIA CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THEY WILL JUST
FIND SOMETHING NEW TO LIE TO YOU
ABOUT.
IF WE REALLY CARE ABOUT TRUTH
AND EQUAL JUSTICE IN THE
UNITED STATES TODAY, TONIGHT THE
DOOR IS WIDE OPEN.
HILLARY CLINTON IS BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDF
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDS
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDA
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDF
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDD
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDA
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDU
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDE
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDC
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDM
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDI
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDT
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES, RAPIDD
USING THOSE BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
HILLARY RUSSIAN LIES, LITERALLY
FRAUD COMMITTED AGAINST JUDGES
TO GET SUBPOENAS TO GET WARRANTS
AGAINST A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE.
THEN AFTER THAT, THE COORDINATED
LEAK EFFORTS TO LITERALLY LIVE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PROPAGANDIZE THEM, MISINFORM
THEM SO THAT WOULD INFLUENCE THE
2016 ELECTION.
THAT ALL NOW NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED IF WE REALLY CARE
ABOUT RUSSIA COLLUSION.
AND EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW,
AND EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR LAW
AND EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR LA,
INTERNET, THE MUELLER PROBE,
THAT SEEMS TO BE WINDING DOWN.
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
REPORTING THAT TRUMP WANTED TO
ORDER THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TO PROSECUTE JAMES COMEY AND
HILLARY CLINTON.
NOW, DOES THAT SOUND LIKE
BREAKING NEWS TO YOU?
BECAUSE, IT ISN'T, IT SHOULDN'T,
AND BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW THE
PRESIDENT FEELS ABOUT HILLARY
AND JAMES COMEY, AND WE KNOW
HILLARY COMMITTED CRIMES.
IT'S NOT EVEN IN DISPUTE.
OF COURSE THE ANTI-TRUMP HATERS
ON FAKE NEWS CNN AND CONSPIRACY
TB MSNBC, ACTING LIKE THEY FOUND
IT.
THEY'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR TWO
YEARS AND NOW THEY FOUND IT.
MAYBE THEY COULD HAVE LISTENED
TO HIS RALLIES THAT THEY
WOULDN'T PLAY WHEN THEY WERE
CHANTING "CNN SUCKS."
>> THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN
AUTHORITARIAN COUNTRIES, THE
PRESIDENT OR LEADER ORDERS THE
PROSECUTION OF HIS POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
>> I THINK IT IS EVIDENCE OF
ABUSE OF POWER.
TO SPEAK OF THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
OFF THE CHARTS.
DONALD TRUMP IS BASICALLY
RUNNING HIS OFFICE LIKE HE OF
THE HEAD OF A BANANA REPUBLIC
BANANA REPUBLIC.
>> I THINK THIS IS A SCANDAL 15
ON A 1-10 LEVEL.
HE WAS ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO USE
THE APPARATUS OF THE STATE TO
PUNISH HIS POLITICAL ENEMIES.
>> Sean: HE NEVER DID
ANYTHING!
NEVER, EVER!
IT'S A PHONY STORY, FAKE NEWS.
WHEN THE A STORY BROKE, WE
REACHED OUT FOR REACTION AND HE
SAID, HOW IS THIS EVEN OUR
STORY?
HE IS RIGHT AND HE WILL JOIN US
LATER WITH MUCH MORE.
DURING THE 2016 CAMPAIGN,
THEN-CANDIDATE TRUMP REPEATEDLY
SAID HE WANTED HILLARY CLINTON
PROSECUTED FOR HER EMAIL SERVERS
SCANDAL, AND CLINTON AND COMEY
BOTH SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATED.
WE ONLY INVESTIGATE TRUMP, I
GUESS, IN THIS POLITICAL CLIMAT
CLIMATE.
HE GAVE HILLARY CLINTON THE
NICKNAME "CROOKED HILLARY" FOR A
REASON.
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED.
THE SINGLE EASIEST SLAM-DUNK
I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
WHEN YOU DELETE EMAILS, PLEAD
THE FIFTH.
BY THE WAY, COMEY'S ACTIONS
LEGALLY NEED TO HAVE BEEN LOOKED
INTO AND IT SHOULD BE.
WHEN WE COME BACK ALSO TONIGHT
LATER ON IN THE PROGRAM, WE WILL
HAVE SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
JOINING US.
HE WILL WEIGH IN ON ALL OF US.
AND NOW WE TURN TO THE SITUATION
WITH SAUDI ARABIA'S CROWN PRINC
PRINCE.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION, THIS WILL
BE VERY HARD FOR THE LIBERALS IN
THE MEDIA TO PAY ATTENTION TO.
I WANT THEM TO PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION.
THE MURDER OF THE SAUDI
JOURNALIST, JAMAL KHASHOGGI, WAS
REPREHENSIBLE.
THAT IS EVIL.
I HAVE LITTLE DOUBT THAT THIS
EVIL ACT WAS CARRIED OUT IN THE
SAUDI CONSULATE AT THE DIRECTION
OF SAUDI ARABIA'S CROWN PRINCE
KNOWN AS M.B.S.
THERE IS NOBODY WHO HAS BEEN
TOUGHER ON SAUDI ARABIA AND
NOBODY MORE CONSISTENT ON MY
CRITICISMS OF SAUDI ARABIA FOR A
WHOLE HOST OF REASON.
I HAVE BEEN THEIR LOUDEST CRITIC
FOR GOOD REASON.
I HAVE CALLED OUT SAUDI ARABIA'S
RAMPANT HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES,
THEIR COMPLETE LACK OF COMMON
DECENCY, SAUDI ARABIA'S
TREATMENT OF WOMEN, THEY CAN'T
DRIVE, UP UNTIL RECENTLY,
COULDN'T VOTE, AND LITERALLY
HAVE TO ASK THEIR HUSBANDS IF
THEY MAY TRAVEL ABROAD, GAY
PEOPLE ARE KILLED JUST FOR BEING
WHO THEY ARE, CHRISTIANS AND
JEWS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO BUILD A
TEMPLE OR CHURCH.
AND UNTIL RECENTLY, WOMEN IN
SAUDI ARABIA COULDN'T DO
ANYTHING WITHOUT BEING AROUND
THE MALE GUARDIAN FROM THEIR
FAMILY OR ELSE THEY WOULD GET IN
TROUBLE.
BY THE WAY, WE MAY NEED
PERMISSION FOR JUST ABOUT
ANYTHING, EVEN TO MARRY, TO
WORK.
BEING GAY IS ILLEGAL, PUNISHABLE
BY DEATH.
CHRISTIAN AND JEWISH TEMPLES
BAND.
THEY ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ACCEPT TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
THINK ABOUT THIS, THE CLINTONS
TOOK TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO ENRICH THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FOUNDATION FROM THE SAUDI
KINGDOM.
WHAT DID THEY GET?
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN AS CRITICAL
AS WE HAVE BEEN.
I WILL CALL OUT EVIL WHEREVER I
SEE IT.
THE MURDER OF JAMAL KHASHOGGI
WAS EVIL.
THE WORLD IS AN UGLY, DANGEROUS,
COMPLICATED PLACE.
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP ISSUED
THIS STATEMENT REAFFIRMING
AMERICA'S STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP
WITH SAUDI ARABIA AND HAD THIS
TO SAY WITH REPORTERS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT THEY TOOK SUCH
UMBRAGE WITH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT IRAN, TAKE A
LOOK AT IRAN, AND LOOK AT WHAT
THEY ARE DOING, THEY ARE A
TERRORIST NATION RIGHT NOW.
ALTHOUGH, I MUST TELL YOU, THEY
ARE A LOT BETTER RIGHT NOW THAN
THEY WERE WHEN I TOOK OFFICE.
WHEN I TOOK OFFICE, THEY WERE
HEADING IN A VERY, VERY BAD
DIRECTION.
AT SOME POINT, THINGS VERY
POSITIVE FRANKLY COULD HAPPEN
WITH IRAN, BUT WE ALSO NEED A
COUNTERBALANCE.
AND ISRAEL NEEDS HELP ALSO.
IF WE ABANDON SAUDI ARABIA, IT
WOULD BE A TERRIBLE MISTAKE.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT IS
RIGHT AND I WANT TO EXPLAIN IN
ALL SPECIFICITY WHY THIS ISN'T
ABOUT POLITICS.
AS EVIL AS THIS KINGDOM IS AS I
HAVE SAID OVER THE YEARS, THE
PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
SAUDI ARABIA HAS NOW EMERGED AT
AN IMPORTANT POINT IN HISTORY AS
A PARTNER IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
LET ME EXPLAIN THIS, AND IT
BRINGS US TO A QUICK "HANNITY"
HISTORY LESSON.
AS A COUNTRY, WE HAVE TO MAKE A
LOT OF TOUGH, VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT STRATEGIC DECISIONS,
NOT LIKE PUTTING MILLIONS IN
YOUR POCKET LIKE OH, THE
CLINTONS.
AND DEAL WITH A LOT OF IMMORAL
AND IN SOME CASES EVIL
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS.
I WILL GIVE YOU ONE QUICK
EXAMPLE, WORLD WAR II.
WE STRUCK ALLIANCES WITH STALIN,
A MASS MURDERER IN RUSSIA, THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION.
THAT EVIL DICTATOR WOULD GO ON
TO MURDER MORE PEOPLE THAN ADOLF
HITLER, BUT THE SURVIVOR OF
AMERICA AND EUROPE WAS IN
JEOPARDY, AND DURING THE
COLD WAR, WE PARTNERED WITH
DOZENS OF BRUTAL DICTATORS TO
VIOLENTLY SQUASH THE SPREAD OF
THE EVILS OF COMMUNISM.
NOW SAUDI ARABIA IS SIMILARLY,
HORRIBLE REGIME, BUT THERE IS A
KEY ALLIANCE THAT IS NOW IN
PLACE, AND THAT WOULD BE THE
UNITED STATES AND ISRAEL, AND
EGYPT, AND JORDAN, AND ALSO,
LET'S SEE, THE SAUDIS, AND THE
EMIRATES.
AND WHAT IS THE ALLIANCE AGAINS
AGAINST?
IRAN.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY THE NUMBER
ONE STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR.
THEY ARE FUNDING NUMEROUS PROXY
WARS.
AND IF THEY WANT TO WIPE ISRAEL
OFF THE MAP, IF THEY EVER GET
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE CAN DIE.
WE HAVE TO MAKE A STRATEGIC
DECISION.
WE CAN'T TAKE THAT RISK.
IN FACT, THE CURRENT ALLIANCE --
AGAIN, THE U.S., ISRAEL, JORDAN,
THE SAUDIS -- THEY HAVE BEEN A
CRUCIAL FORCE IN CHECKING THIS
IRANIAN HEDGE ENEMY.
THIS IS THE ALLIANCE WE NOW
NEED TO STOP THESE RADICAL
THREATS FROM EVER GETTING THEIR
HANDS ON NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
STILL MANY ON THE LEFT ARE IN
MELTDOWN MODE OVER THE
PRESIDENT'S HANDLING OF
SAUDI ARABIA.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHERE HAVE THEY BEEN?
FORMER OBAMA U.S. INVESTOR,
SAMANTHA POWER TWEETING, "IT IS
A MEAN AND NASTY WORLD BUT TRUMP
SIDING WITH THE MEANEST AND
NASTIEST OUT THERE, WHETHER
VLADIMIR PUTIN, OR ASSASSIN
M.B.S. WILL LEAVE THE WORLD EVEN
NASTIER."
THIS STATEMENT IS A GREEN LIGHT
FOR WOULD-BE MURDERERS IN
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE THINGS TRUMP
THINGS WE NEED TO."
HOW ABOUT A HISTORY LESSON FOR
YOU, MAYBE YOU FORGOT ABOUT YOUR
TIME AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE IT WAS
BARACK HUSSEIN OBAMA WHO SENT
TANKS, F-16 FIGHTER JETS, OVER
$1 BILLION TO A GUY BY THE NAME
OF MOHAMMED MORSI, HE WAS WITH
THE RADICAL MUSLIM BROTHERHOOD
THAT ROSE TO POWER IN EGYPT.
MOHAMMED MORSI, THE GUY WHO ONCE
REFERRED TO PEOPLE IN ISRAEL AND
JEWS AS THE DESCENDANTS OF APES
AND PIGS IN THE MUSLIM
BROTHERHOOD FUNDING TERRORISM
AROUND THE WORLD.
BY THE WAY, THAT IS YOUR FORMER
BOSS, OBAMA, WHO PARTNERED WITH
THEM FOR NO STRATEGIC REASON.
OBAMA GIFTED THAT GUY BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, MATERIAL SUPPORT,
PLANES, TANKS, AND COLD HARD
CASH.
WE CAN'T FORGET THAT YEAH, OBAMA
ALSO PARTNERED WITH THE RADICAL
STATE SPONSORS OF TERROR AND A
HORRIBLY FLAWED NUCLEAR DEAL,
THE U.S. AND $1.7 BILLION IN
CASH AND OTHER CURRENCY DIRECTLY
TO THEM.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO PLOTTED THE
DESTRUCTION OF ISRAEL AND THE
UNITED STATES ON A DAILY BASIS,
AND THANK GOD IS INSTRUCTING
THEM TO DO IT, AND TREAT WOMEN
AND CHRISTIANS AND JEWS AND
EVERYONE ELSE.
SO PLEASE, SPARE US THE FAINT
MORAL OUTRAGE.
REMEMBER, AS I POINTED OUT
EARLIER, HILLARY CLINTON TOTALLY
IGNORE THE SAUDI ARABIA
TREATMENT OF WOMEN AND
CHRISTIANS BECAUSE THEY BOUGHT
HER SILENCE.
SHE IS NEVER CRITICIZED THE WAY
WE HAVE REGULARLY ON THIS
PROGRAM.
TODAY, WITH IRAN NOW POSING THE
SINGLE BIGGEST THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES, THE MIDDLE EAST,
AND THE WORLD, THIS STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIP WITH SAUDI ARABIA IS
TOO IMPORTANT, IF AT ALL
POSSIBLE, TO DISMANTLE.
WE CAN KEEP IT TOGETHER.
IT'S SMART.
IT'S INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED,
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, AND ON TOP OF THAT,
THOUGH SAUDIS ARE SPENDING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON WEAPONS PURCHASES THAT, BY
THE WAY, BOTH RUSSIA AND CHINA
WANTED, AND WE GOT.
THAT MEANS, WHAT?
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE, LET'S SEE,
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND THE LEADERS
OF CHINA RICH AGAIN?
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA
TO TAKE AMERICAN JOBS AWAY FROM
THEM.
I AM NOT WILLING TO DO THAT.
DO WE WANT TO HELP OUT, PUT A
NEW ALLIANCE TOGETHER?
LET'S SEE, THE IRANIANS,
SYRIANS, CHINA, VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND RUSSIA?
IT'S A DARK, EVIL, UGLY WORLD AT
TIMES.
FOR MORE COMPLICATED THAN WHAT
LIBERAL NETWORKS THAT HATE
DONALD TRUMP EVEN, YOU KNOW,
TAKING A BREATH COULD EVER
POSSIBLY UNDERSTAND.
WE HAVE TO TURN TO ANOTHER
SITUATION CLOSER TO HOME.
FOR WEEKS, WE'VE BEEN SOUNDING
THE ALARM ABOUT THE MASSIVE
CARAVAN OF MIGRANTS MARCHING
TOWARDS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE HAVE TRACKED THEM THROUGH
CENTRAL AMERICA AS THEY BROKE
DOWN GUATEMALA'S BORDER FENCE,
STORMED INTO SOUTHERN MEXICO.
WE HAVE FOLLOWED THIS JOURNEY
NORTH TOWARDS THE U.S. BORDER
AND WARNED ABOUT POSSIBLE GAMING
AND CRIMINAL INFILTRATION.
WE SHOWED YOU HOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PREPARED FOR THE
APPROACHING CARAVAN.
THOUSANDS OF ACTIVE-DUTY TROOPS
WERE SENT TO THE BORDER, RAZOR
WIRE WAS DEPLOYED TO BOLSTER THE
FENCING, AND NEW BARRIERS WERE
ALSO CONSTRUCTED.
HARDWORKING U.S. BORDER PATROL
AGENTS STEPPED THEIR EFFORTS UP.
A SERIOUS SITUATION, BUT NOT
ACCORDING TO THE DEMOCRATS.
REMEMBER FOR A WHILE THEY WERE
IGNORING THE MIGRANT CARAVAN AND
ACCUSING REPUBLICANS OF
FABRICATING THIS PHONY CRISIS IN
THE LEAD UP TO AN ELECTION FOR
POLITICAL GAIN?
OTHERS CALLED ALL A CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
OBAMA LAUGHED AT THE IDEA.
AT ONE EVENT HE WAS SPEAKING AT.
NO, IT'S A REAL SITUATION WITH
REAL CONSEQUENCES.
WE NOW KNOW OUR OWN DHS AND
LEADERS IN MEXICO SAYING THAT
OVER 500 CRIMINALS ARE NOW
TRAVELING WITH THE MIGRANT, AND
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT,
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS EVEN PAID
UNDERCOVER INFORMANTS TO ADDRESS
SECURITY THREATS.
BY THE WAY, THAT IS CALLED BEING
SMART.
YESTERDAY WE SAW IN TIJUANA,
AUTHORITIES HAVING TO ARREST 34
MEMBERS OF THAT CARAVAN FOR
OFFENSES LIKE PUBLIC
INTOXICATION, DISTURBING THE
PEACE, RESISTING ARREST.
DESPITE ALL OF THIS, THE FEDERAL
JUDGE YESTERDAY IN
SAN FRANCISCO, WHAT A SHOCK,
DEALT A BLOW TO THE PRESIDENT'S
BORDER SECURITY EFFORTS IN THE
RULE OF LAW, STRIKING DOWN A
TEMPORARY ASYLUM BAN ON THOSE
WHO DON'T APPLY AT A PORT OF
ENTRY.
SEE WHY HOLDING THE U.S. SENATE
AND THE PRESIDENT NOW
CAMPAIGNING AND PICKING UP SEATS
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 100 YEARS,
A SITTING PRESIDENT THAT GETS
THE WHITE HOUSE, IS ABLE TO DO
THIS IN HIS FIRST MIDTERM
ELECTION.
AS I'VE BEEN TELLING YOU, THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE JUST
SEARCHING FOR A BETTER LIFE.
I GET THAT, BUT WE HAVE GOT TO
BET ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO COME
HERE.
500 CRIMINALS INFILTRATED,
WALKING WITH THE CARAVAN PEOPLE.
IT EVEN WHITE MEXICAN PEOPLE NOW
ARE PROTESTING THE CARAVAN AND
SAYING THAT THEY HAVE EVEN BEEN
INVADED.
ECHOING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TOUGH
TALK ON THE BOARD APPEARED TO
TAKE LOOK.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> Sean: AN INVASION.
THERE ARE NOW THOUSANDS ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT SAID THEY
WOULD NEVER GET THERE.
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY IS ABOUT
MORE THAN JUST A SECURITY
UNINVITED, UNCHECKED, MASS
MIGRATION COMES AT A MASSIVE
COST, YOU, WE THE PEOPLE, THE
TAXPAYERS.
ANY REPORT EXPOSING HOW YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, PAY FOR
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO THE JUNE OF
$18.5 BILLION A YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
IMMIGRATION STUDIES, ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSSINGS ARE UP.
COMES WITH IT, A MASSIVE PRICE
TAG FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE ON THIS
DEVELOPING SITUATION ALSO
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
TONIGHT, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
ALL BUT REFUSING TO COVER THE
CRISIS AT THE BORDER, BUT
INSTEAD, THEY ARE BUSY OBSESSING
OVER A VULGAR TERM.
SHE BRIEFLY USED A PRIVATE EMAIL
ACCOUNT, THIS GOES BACK 15
MONTHS AGO TO SEND AND RECEIVE
SOME THAT WERE WORK-RELATED
MESSAGES.
TALKING ABOUT A FEW HUNDRED
EMAILS, 15 MONTHS AGO, SHE WAS
NEW ON THE JOB, NEW TO
WASHINGTON, ALL OF THE EMAILS
HAVE BEEN HANDED OVER TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE SAYING THIS IS LIKE
HILLARY, ALTHOUGH THEY NEVER
CRITICIZED HER.
NOTHING HAS BEEN DELETED, A
NONSTORY.
NO CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
BUT HILLARY CLINTON, WHEN SHE
WAS CONDUCTING STATE DEPARTMENT
BUSINESS WITH AN EMAIL, A
BATHROOM MOM-AND-POP COMPANY,
MANY OF THOSE EMAILS SHE SENT
AND RECEIVED WORD TOP SECRET.
SHE LIED TO US.
WE CAN PROVE THE LIE.
THOUSANDS OF EMAILS WERE DELETE
DELETED.
GUESS WHAT, NONE OF THESE WERE
TURNED OVER TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, AND THERE WERE MEDIA
REMAINED SILENT.
THEY COVERED FOR THEIR FRIENDS,
THE CLINTONS.
NOW ARE THEY TREATING THE
IVANKA, YOU KNOW, THE NONSTORY
LIKE THE BIGGEST SCANDAL OF THE
CENTURY.
WHAT A BUNCH OF PHONY
HYPOCRITES.
TO SPEAK OF THE ARROGANCE, THE
INCREDIBLE ARROGANCE WITH A
LITTLE MEASURE OF STUPIDITY.
>> IT'S POSSIBLE SHE IS
CONSIDERED A PRINCESS AND
TOTALLY SEPARATE FROM THE REST
OF THE RULES THE AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT AND THE PRESIDENT,
CABINET, AND ADVISORS GO BY.
>> WHEN THE NEW CONGRESS GETS
SWORN IN, THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE, THEY NEED TO SEEK
NOTHING LESS OF IVANKA TRUMP AND
HER LAWYER THAN THE TRUTH, THE
WHOLE TRUTH, AND NOTHING BUT THE
TRUTH.
>> THEY REALLY ARE A MOB FAMILY.
THEY BASICALLY TOOK WHAT THEY
WERE DOING IN THE BUSINESS, THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION, AND BROUGHT
IT TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY DIDN'T CARE AT ALL WHAT THE
RULES WERE AND WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO.
>> Sean: THEY DIDN'T COVER
HILLARY CLINTON'S CRIMES.
WE KNOW SHE COMMITTED CRIMES.
THIS IS HYPOCRISY IN ACTION.
THIS IS WHY SO MANY AMERICANS
DON'T TRUST THE PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA -- NOR SHOULD DO.
IT DESTROYED TRUMP EVERY SECOND,
EVERY MINUTE, EVERY HOUR, EVERY
DAY.
THEY ARE JUST HYPOCRITES.
TWO WEEKS AGO, THE MEDIA
IGNORING THE STORY, JAMES COMEY
WAS USING PRIVATE EMAIL FOR FBI
BUSINESS.
BASICALLY CRICKETS.
YOU DIDN'T HEAR THE SAME TYPE OF
CRITICISM.
IT'S THE SAME REASON NOW MEMBERS
OF THE MEDIA NOW TOTALLY
IGNORING THEIR FORMER BFF,
MICHAEL AVENATTI APPEARED FOR SO
MANY MONTHS HE WAS THE POSTER
CHILD ON FAKE NEWS CNN,
CONSPIRACY TB MSNBC, SPREADING
FILE CLAIMS AGAINST JUST A
KAVANAUGH THAT THEY WERE
SPREADING AND BELIEVING.
THEY BELIEVED.
GUESS WHAT?
THE LEFT, ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY
CHANGED THEIR GUILT BY
ACCUSATION MOTTO.
THE NEW STANDARD THEY CREATED IN
AMERICA.
YET NO ONE IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, ALL OF AVENATTI'S
FRIENDS, THEY ARE PRETTY MUCH
SILENT AND PRETTY MUCH NOT
SAYING ANYTHING.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS THE ISSUE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT IS SO
SERIOUS, THAT IS NOT WHAT
MATTERS TO THEM, BECAUSE IF IT
DID, THEY WOULDN'T BE BEST
FRIENDS WITH THE CLINTON'S,
WOULD THEY?
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE WORSHIPED
THE MEDIA OR BEEN WORSHIPED BY
THE MEDIA AS THEY HAVE BEEN.
AND KEITH ELLISON WOULD HAVE
BEEN VETTED AND CALLED OUT.
THE ISSUE REALLY SEEMS TO BE
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR CHARGES LIKE
THIS IMPORTANT ONLY IF THEY CAN
BLUDGEON A REPUBLICAN.
THEN THERE IS NO DUE PROCESS,
THERE IS NO PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
WHERE IS ALL THE OUTRAGE ON
THESE CHANNELS, THEIR BEST
FRIENDS?
IF YOU ARE ON THE LEFT, THE
RULES DON'T APPLY TO YOU.
ONE SET OF GESTURES FOR THEM,
AND THE GUILLOTINE PRETTY MUCH
FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA'S
POSTELECTION SPIN DOESN'T HELP
EITHER.
THE DELUSIONAL MEDIA ARE NOW
TRYING TO PULL A FAST BALL ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SAYING TRUMP
HAS BEEN REJECTED, THIS HAS BEEN
A MASSIVE BLUE WAVE.
HIS PRESIDENCY HAS BEEN
CONTAINED BY SOME IMAGINARY BLUE
WAVE.
IN HISTORICAL TERMS, IT WAS A
TRICKLE.
SOME DEMOCRATS REFUSING TO EVEN
CALL THE ELECTION LEGITIMATE IN
RACES THAT DIDN'T GO THEIR WAY.
WE SAW THAT IN GEORGIA IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
BRIAN CAMP WON OUTRIGHT, BUT
STACY ABRAMS SAID IN GEORGIA DID
NOT HAVE A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION AND BRIAN CAMP
DISMANTLED THE DEMOCRACY.
REALLY CLASSY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A SORE LOSERRISM.
ACCORDING TO FOX'S ACCOUNT, THE
DEMOCRATS WON 232 SEATS IN THE
HOUSE COMPARED TO 199 FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
MORE RACES YET TO BE CALLED.
THEY PICKED UP 37 SEATS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, BUT THEY LOST ALL
THOSE SEATS AND CLAIRE
McCASKILL IS OUT, AND NELSON
IS OUT, AND DONNELLY IS OUT.
OH, YEAH.
SO, PRESIDENT TRUMP, IF YOU
ACTUALLY LOOK AT NUMBERS AND
HISTORY DID CONSIDERABLY IT
MASSIVELY BETTER THE PREVIOUS
TWO DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTS.
2010, OBAMA'S FIRST MIDTERM.
DEMOCRATIC LOST 63 SEATS IN THE
HOUSE, '94, BILL CLINTON LOST 52
SEATS IN THE HOUSE AND ATE IN
THE SENATE.
BEAR IN MIND, THE REPUBLICANS
ACTUALLY ADDED TO THEIR SENATE
MAJORITY AND BY THE WAY, THAT
NUMBER IS LIKELY TO GROW NEXT
WEEK.
AN IMPORTANT ELECTION.
IF YOU ARE IN MISSISSIPPI, THAT
SPECIAL ELECTION, NOVEMBER 27TH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE STUMPING
FOR HYDE SMITH IN HER BID TO
BECOME THE FIRST FEMALE SENATOR
FROM THE GREAT STATE OF
MISSISSIPPI.
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT VOTE IF YOU
LIVE THERE.
THIS IS A BIG RACE.
REPUBLICAN VICTORY MEANS 53-47